it's a Bittersweet day for Gloria three
years after her father George
chandrasekharan was killed with 268
others in churches and hotels across Sri
Lanka's capital on Easter Sunday there's
some accountability as a citizen of this
country I'm happy because at some point
we got a Justice it's kind of a winning
Wicket for us but as a daughter of
George I'm not happy because I may get
get million billion or trillions but
those that money cannot bring my Dada
back on Thursday the Supreme Court ruled
former Sri Lankan president maitripala
sirisena and four senior security
officials violated the rights of the
bomb victims by failing to protect them
they were ordered to pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars in compensation to
the victims families the then Secretary
of the ministry of Defense the police
chief and heads of the two main
intelligence agencies were the others
who were fined at the center of the
petitions filed in court was the fact
that the government had received
intelligence regarding a possible attack
nearly three weeks before the bombings
and did nothing to prevent them the
court said we conclude that the former
president sirisena has been lacks in
affording the protection and guarantees
in joined under the Constitution and
other laws and he has breached his duty
to protect adding that this dismal
failure on the part of the former
president sirisena resulted in
disastrous consequences for this country
ahead of the attacks the government was
divided after president sirisena's
failed attempt to sack his prime
minister the now President Ronald Vikram
singer and replace him with the defeated
president behind the rajapak sir many
here believe this division may have
affected crucial aspects like National
Security
observers say the two camps were so busy
fighting each other they failed to act
on valuable intelligence the Supreme
Court acknowledged this fact saying
there a specificity exactitude and
clarity as to the likely attackers modes
of attack and their targets the victims
families welcomed the decision but say
there's more work to be done to find
those who carried out those attacks and
bring them to justice a few days after
the bombings isil claimed responsibility
but many doubt that claim the government
has filed more than 23 000 charges
against a group of at least 40 suspects
accusations of possible involvement by
intelligence operatives claims of
cover-ups and allegations by the
Archbishop of Colombo that the bombings
were part of the plot to bring the
rajbak's brothers back to Power have not
been investigated I do want Justice
please I can sleep peacefully
we as victims Cry For Justice like
Gloria many victims say they will
continue their campaign until they find
the truth Minna Fernandez Al Jazeera
Colombo